whose land is this
my land
well well well our war hero has arrived
you've been a good choice going back
here let's say he's our the finest
wealthiest and most beautiful people on
God's Earth they outsmarted everybody
they have the same who gets the oil
I got a question you like women that's
my weakness
well we mix these families together and
that state money flows the right
direction it'll come to us
that's how you are I don't know what you
said but it must have been Indian for
handsome devil
[Music]
why did you come here
you're scared of him
oh easy he's the nicest man in the world
the old sage their time is over
we've got a Chase back control of our
home
I was sent down from Washington DC to
see about these murders
we have so many deaths we've lost count
this just
and look seems more like an epidemic
than bad luck to me
[Music]
Osage is dying by the enemy
do not let them die alone
evil surrounds my heart
side
I don't even know if you love me anymore
kill these men who killed my family
did your wife say who she was most
afraid of
[Applause]
don't do something you're gonna regret
for the rest of your life
[Music]
I ain't got nothing but regret